hi guys how is your tournament going so
far so good so far so good yeah how many
points are you on I'm not sure but I'm
on plus four just players are bad at
counting points but they know how many
games they won okay and your T it's
going pretty bad okay but there's still
a long tournament to go right and the
whole Blitz events as well speaking of
it's a really long tournament you have
13 Rounds how do you maintain energy uh
after so many
rounds okay you have to do it anyway
yeah maybe you you don't maintain
anything but at the end of the day you
have to go through it so like my my
advice is to make some short brw
sometimes but um for the kids it's
probably not like a very inspirational
example
[Music]
yeah good luck for the rest of the
tournament I hope the blitz goes better
we'll we be watching you and yeah thank
you very much now we will go to an ad
break